going to welcome to this video playing
FM and I cannot pronounce it I'm sorry
about it I cannot get [ __ ] know that
that was completely wrong and 356 is the
way it is usually played yet yeah but
this isn't this just good food like I'm
in the dark squares up the ad and so on
even fif is possible here I mean
and I keynotes just cancel I mean so
yeah maybe as five or just 94 let's
connect to form
probably not threatening won't be too
long maybe you can even get away with
Nigeria maybe you can okay so what's
going on here chicken here sg3
why a five-year to bust this open
Queen deform to trade on your queen g5
is also move here take g3 with check and
threaten night xf3
and it cannot cancel any more and I g4
is the the obvious move just one that
says something better it looks good
looks fine we are 93 I guess again
attacking g3
I mean I can't rate queens of a P sub
but I really feel like I should check
made them come on okay okay it's a piece
white design okay I think that this is
already sorry pretty bad it is just
weakens the dark squares only goes ahead
like a million moves which is weakens
the the dark squares quite quite
immensely if anything I think why should
play you for here are 193 this is the
Bliss nothing better I mean he just has
extremely bad dark squares and the
internals are already pretty drastic
about this position I'm actually not
sure that this is good because of three
of 93 I wasn't sure about this yeah it
wasn't even good at night before we
cannot play this month i mean i can but
no it doesn't do much this this is kind
of defending yeah this is comfortable
but nothing special and this is down
just a piece check check check
hmm yeah that did the opening line is
not good yet I should play for here on
93 these are probably better I say I
think it's nothing much anyway for white
but this is Sir this is a good term the
anise is better than what was for played
in the game I think this is the the move
but irritated that stock which shows
night before I don't think that works
actually i have i recommended be five in
my repertoire there was something wrong
with the smooth but i don't quite know
it don't quite remember maybe it was a
draw anything i wanted to avoid it i'm
not quite sure ok guys thanks for
watching